اعلن المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه كريم خان عن استعداد المحكمه
للتعاون الكامل مع مكتب المدعي العام
لاوكرانيا لتحقيق في الجرائم المرتكبه ضد
الاوكرانيين خلال العدوان الشامل وفق
تعبيره من جهه
الى العداله جراء الجرائم التي ارتكبوها
في الاراضي الاوكرانيه على حد قوله
سيدنا
من المؤكد ان سياسه الاباده الجماعيه التي
تنتهجها روسيا ستكون لها عواقب قانونيه
حتميه على كل من صاغها ووافق عليها ونفذها
والامر لا يتعلق بالجنه فقط بل بالقياده
السياسيه والعسكريه العليا للدوله
الارهابيه ايضا وقد تحدثنا عن ذلك مع
المدعي العام لدى المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه خلال اجتماع في كييف ومن الواضح
ان هذه ليست بالمهمه السهله ولكن الرد على
الجرائم الروسيه بالقانون ومن خلال الس
لطه المحكمه الدوليه احد الضمانات لامن
الاوكرانيين مستقبلا وانني اعلنوا اننا
على وشك افتتاح المكتب الاوكراني للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه